We've been taught that women don't belong in the kitchen
because it's a waste of time,
demeaning. Because cooking is too hard and takes too much time.
And that quality food is best purchased in a package.
This has caused us to become fully disconnected from our food source.
We don't work with our hands.
We don't know where our food is from or how it was produced.
Nutrient density has no meaning when we eat their processed foods
and their convenience foods,
their food that shouldn't be considered food.
We fill their pockets with money.
Today, society is sicker than ever.
Disease is rampant.
But does anyone wonder why we become so disconnected from our food?
That we have forgotten that food is thy medicine
and thy medicine is thy food?